you said
you know
ups and downs in your childhood a little
rough sometimes
um also you get attacked by the
beautiful wonderful people on the
internet sure so sometimes it's
difficult what's uh what's been the
lowest point that you've ever gone to in
your mind
in my career in my life in your life in
your career and everything your mind so
have you uh ever been depressed
for sure yes how how did you like if you
can remember moments how did you
overcome that
well I I will share two anecdotes uh one
when I was
uh May 2012 so I was uh 16 and a half
and I
was living
in a household situation where
I thought nobody knew what was going on
basically without sharing obviously
extremely personal details like what was
going on except me
and I confided in my grandmother
I
was imagine living in a house where you
basically feel like a prisoner you don't
want to interact with anybody in the
house you don't know how you're supposed
to bring these things up
of course this sounds extremely vague
and I just don't I don't feel like
exposing all of my entire family drama
to the audience but I live this way for
probably something like
eight months I don't know something
ridiculous it was a junior year of high
school so I was supposed to take my SATs
that was the year I was supposed to
finish up my portfolio for college
because you only get really a few months
of senior years to start applying it was
a [ __ ] it was a nightmare complete
Nightmare and
I I don't know how I got through it time
went by I listened to sad music and
tried to spend as little time as home as
possible I would pretend to fall asleep
at my friend's houses so that my mom was
like you coming for dinner and I'll just
pretend to be asleep
it was just a grind yeah yeah it was it
was a grind I I don't remember a whole
lot from from that period just sort of
finding what made me happy and trying to
focus on it and I was a teenager in the
house I wasn't going to run away I still
had a roof over my head so I'm not not
saying I had a better or worse than
others I just had a different
uh and actually recently this is much
more on my memory uh I
more or less tore up a very happy life
my wife and I had and I've talked about
this in bursts on stream
but essentially what happened was
uh we we had just been living in
that's actually funny the way we got
into this apartment was was also very
bad but we were living in just a very
like nice little apartment like
high-rise apartment safe and the reason
we moved into a high-rise was because we
had lived in a house for two weeks that
got broken into
not because of who I am but because we
suspect we had people moving in
mattresses and they went oh [ __ ] these
two people live here that's it and
basically there was three Apartments my
upstairs neighbor let in somebody that
they didn't expect and the guy cracked
our door open with a crowbar thank God
that was the first day in two years my
wife went to work
did they know did they not know I don't
know everything happens for a reason
so everybody got hurt nobody nobody got
hurt yeah they stole they they stole
them some couple of important things but
nobody was hurt uh and the cops did
nothing
so you uh they moved into a high-rise in
New York yeah in New York for for safety
and we're away from things and we have
our own nice little Nook
and somewhere some months into it I
started hearing noises from above our
neighbors
and it started in the morning 7 A.M it
started in the afternoon and
I picked up on it
and I expected it every day for weeks
then it was driving me crazy and I was
like okay we're gonna go have a civil
conversation with who's ever up there
sounds like kids
so we go knock lady Gaslight the [ __ ]
out of us I've never been gaslit that
hard in my life she went noise what
noise it's probably our other neighbor
who's a boxer
lady you have kids we can hear you
through the vents hear you talking to
your kids went to the front desk of the
building they did nothing went to the
leasing office they did nothing and
basically over time I just let this
drive me nuts this was back to the
stubbornness thing I I decided we were
leaving we were going to live somewhere
there was no noise because we can't beat
these people there's there's nothing we
can do right and
my wife I dragged her around to a bunch
of different viewings that was dead set
I was I was decided I was completely
miserable
and
I we found a house to rent like a nice
house family had just moved away house
Standalone house not gonna have
neighbors
but wife decided that
wife decided we decided that the it's
too big it's too big for so we're gonna
get a dog we always wanted an animal so
we're gonna get a dog
so we get an absolute lunatic puppy who
just doesn't let us sleep at all this is
on top of everything else the Mental
Health crisis that's going on and the
day we are moving to this house
I realize I [ __ ] up like I realized that
this whole thing
was in my head and I don't want to leave
I don't want to leave this could have
all been avoided
and the guilt and res I didn't want to
exist like it's not that I it wasn't
suicide but you know what the feeling of
just you want to just observe yourself
from a distance yeah and I couldn't
sleep I thought my wife was gonna leave
me like this is my and that's what
anxiety does it also takes everything
you feel to an absolute dread and that I
experienced
for a good chunk of two weeks
and then we kind of settle down and
decided like we're gonna live you tell
her about it like were you able to talk
through it yeah yeah I yeah that you
know the levels of Madness that could be
inside your mind I don't know if she'll
ever know but I tried to tell her that
and uh give glimpses yes I'm not I'm not
sure you'll ever know I cut off the
point yeah I try to that's why I try to
keep busy but that was that was the
darkest that got and yet through all of
that I went on stream every day I made
YouTube videos every day like I
understood that I had a job to do and
and I did it and I talked about it here
and there but that was that was the
worst that I ever got because
I'm learning that the emotions I
experience are guilt remorse and your
brain just goes in circles basically
about things that you've done or haven't
done it's funny because noise I do that
also so no the noise was real but it was
building in your head yeah
so I I try to I actually
it's kind of funny because I like to
focus deeply you know I'll have like
sources of noise I've tried to teach
myself over time I'll go to like coffee
shops and stuff to like I like I almost
try to put myself next to annoying
situations so I get like trained really
maybe I should do that but it's at a
certain point at the same time I've
gotten to hang out with certain people
especially in La they're like in the
middle of nowhere like a Malibu or
something and it's like that quiet it
can you hear your ears ringing it's so
quiet basically yeah and it's like holy
[ __ ] this is a good place this is a good
way if you want to write something or
create something this is like super
quiet so my mom does my mom's a science
journalist science author she just
published her first her first book
actually on the poop of all things yeah
fecal the waste management is actually
very fascinating concept and look
through history and she would do that
she goes to complete Solitude yeah and
she writes yeah
it's beautiful no Sirens I mean New York
is the opposite of that so you know it's
you you've you've brought it uh
you brought on yourself I I've lived
there for 20 years it has it been tough
like going on stream to put on the face
of Happiness through that yeah
yes but I find my ways to have moments
where I can talk about it if it's on a
stream I don't get 10 000 live viewers
so it's very different it's if I stream
late night I get a 1500 2 000 viewers I
used to care a lot more about viewers on
on stream but I've basically invested
fully in YouTube so that's kind of the
way I and I think I don't know maybe you
can correct me but I think people
appreciate
the the human being behind the chess
streamer I think so
I think so I think a lot of people
not in the Chess World but just a lot of
people they put on a Persona and just in
general social media is the highlights
of your life or the low light is just as
long as they're dramatic
but I I've tried I try to be very open
and honest when I'm tired I'm tired it's
what makes my recaps of my tournaments I
think so real
yeah man you're an incredible person
I've been a fan for a long time it's
kind of funny that we connected with God
and she has to talk uh please please
keep creating keep teaching people for
now I'm not going anywhere
well
it could end at any moment
as we talked about so yeah uh thank you
so much for talking today man thank you
for everything you do it was an honor it
was great thanks for having me on